remember rule of thumb we've talked  about this many times rule of thumb  people don't buy a house based on the  loan amount or the interest rate people  buy a house based on the payment no one  goes to the bank and says give me a six  hundred thousand dollar loan they go and  say I can't afford five thousand dollars  a month what size loan does that qualify  for no one goes and says I want a  million dollar loan they ask they solve  for payment so the payment just doubled  give or take so the average person's  like hey I can't afford a eight thousand  dollar payment six thousand dollar  payments okay good luck  you went from an 800 000 home to now six  hundred thousand what are you talking  about I can't get nothing for six  hundred thousand totally get it but  that's what just happened but but  reality is going to sink in in 2023